selena gomez and the weeknd step out  matching in nyc cause i just wanna look  good for you  [Music]  selena and the 27 year old starboy  singer were spotted hand-in-hand leaving  a lunch date at lower fish bar in soho  new york on saturday can't keep my hands  to myself the pair looked too cute in  their all-black matching ensembles  selena rocking a slightly edgier style  in an oversized black t-shirt matching  flared jeans and a leather jacket she  paired the look with a red handbag hoop  earrings and her hair pulled back into a  messy ponytail i feel free more than  i've ever felt in my whole life while  the weekend also sported an oversized  black tea and matching jeans opting for  a black bomber jacket over his chic  threads  selena recently opened up about her  relationship with the weekend in the  september issue of instyle magazine  telling the publication he's her quote  best friend it's a great feeling